Graduates, guests, faculty and staff.
Welcome to the 2021 MSX
graduation ceremony at
the Stanford University Graduate School
of Business.
11 months ago,
you arrived here at the GSB and
I welcomed your class over Zoom.
I am so
happy that we are here together in SEMX.
We have definitely come a long
way over the past year.
Now, before we begin the ceremony,
I'd like to start by recognizing
our guests, the families and
friends who have provided support and
made the effort to be here today.
Let's have a round of applause for
our guests.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> And
I'd also like to share a brief video
message of congratulations from
Stanford's President Mirth Cassia Vivian.
>> Good afternoon, and
congratulations to each of you on earning
your Masters of Science in Management.
During your time at Stanford,
you've explored intellectually,
we find your skills and reflected on your
careers and your goals for the future.
I'm always impressed
with our MSX students for
taking the time to invest in themselves
that advance their knowledge.
But your cohort in particular took on
this task at a deeply uncertain time.
You persevere through a delayed start,
adapted to new ways of learning, and
built a strong community,
despite the challenges you faced.
The spirit of leadership determination and
commitment that you honed
through this experience will help you
measurably throughout your careers.
Your hard work and
dedication are brought to you today,
and I hope you're all tremendously proud.
As you join the ranks of Stanford alumni,
I urge you to use your talents and
the skills you've honed here to
shape the lives you want to lead and
to contribute to our broader world.
I can't wait to see what you do next,
congratulations once again,
on your remarkable achievements.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> A graduation
ceremony is about celebrating what you've
achieved and what you will go on to do.
And I'd like to start by looking back and
let's start by rolling back
the clock to the fall of 2019.
You're all leading your lives
very successful lives by
all accounts spread out all over
the globe in more than 20 countries,
working in different industries finance,
healthcare, tech education government.
Many of you had advanced degrees
already many of you had children
spouses mortgages.
You were leading teams,
the mortgage part yeah,
you were leading teams,
some of you had started organizations.
And yet you wanted something more,
you wanted to think about your career,
your life, how you might take it in
a new direction or to the next level.
You are dreaming bigger, and
that led you to Stanford, or
you thought that was
leading you to Stanford.
Of course, March 2020 rolled around and
had other plans for all of us.
And the GSB, like the rest of the world,
had to move online, and your path here
became much less straightforward.
We made a difficult decision to postpone
the start date of your program,
making you unique in
the history of the GSB.
And of course you had
many factors to consider.
Your jobs, your family, visas,
housing, expiring, GMAT scores.
Not to mention maintaining your own
physical and mental at the onset and
that of your family at
the onset of the pandemic.
And you had to answer a basic question,
would it make sense to put
everything on hold and come to Stanford
for a year to study business and
to study leadership in
the midst of a global pandemic?
Well, you're here so
clearly the answer was yes.
And Martin Luther King, Jr. once said,
you don't have to see the whole staircase,
just take the first step.
You took that step, and you didn't know
how the program was going to go or
whether we would be able to resume in
person learning whether you would ever
meet The faculty members in person or
your classmates for that matter.
You took that step and you took a risk.
And that says a lot about you,
individually and collectively.
And over the last year you move from
interacting with each other over Zoom to
sharing classrooms with your cohort to the
Super Summer and now to the full quarter.
And you came together as a class.
You planned virtual kids events,
you held MSX moments,
conversations with professors and
other speakers at EVGR.
You've been drove around apparently
in a pickup truck helping your other
classmates move.
You took paths to power with Jeff Pfeffer.
David Krebs pushed your
knowledge of micro economics,
Jennifer Aaker enlightened you about the
relationship between business and humor.
You refined your leadership skills and
interpersonal dynamics in
managing growing enterprises.
You earned the admiration of our faculty.
In fact,
some of our faculty are now advocating to
teach their classes in MSX only elective.
[APPLAUSE] You've taken
the time to think about
what you want to do,
you want to change your career,
maybe start a company with
someone you've met here.
Or maybe you've realized that you want to
return to your job, to your industry but
with a new perspective.
The magic of being at Stanford is being
exposed to a breadth of people of ideas
of skills of different approaches
to management and leadership.
One thing is certain.
There will be many opportunities for
each of you in the years to come.
And I hope that when you remember this
year, you will remember it both for
the opportunities it created and
for the people that you met.
And for the chance that you had to reset
and reflect on your own aspirations,
about how you wanted to pursue the next
phase of your career and your lives.
And I hope you will do that in ways
that are filled with meaning and
contribute to the greater good.
You are graduating at a time of enormous
change and acceleration of technology,
a rethinking of work the opportunity
to build and reshape organizations.
And with the skills and the knowledge
that will help you go on in business to
tackle some of the great challenges and
changes of our time.
A time of disruption and
change is exactly the moment when
a Stanford education is the most valuable.
And more than other classes
perhaps more than any other class.
You've learned how to deal with
uncertainty and with ambiguity,
to be adaptable, to be resilient.
And those are powerful lessons for
your career and your life.
MSX class of 2021 congratulations.
I wish you all the best.
[APPLAUSE] And now I have the great
pleasure of introducing our
graduation speaker Noosheen Hashemi,
a graduate of the MSX class of 1993.
Noosheen is a tech veteran,
an entrepreneur, an investor,
a philanthropist.
She is the founder and CEO of January AI,
a precision health tech company that
harnesses the power of artificial
intelligence to prevent, predict,
postpone and manage chronic disease.
Noosheen also guides a family office that
includes investments
in over 100 companies.
She is a co-founder and president of
the Hand foundation, dedicated to building
better communities by enabling the growth
and advancement of individuals.
She has received numerous public
honors including the summer,
the World Economic Forum
recognizing her and her company,
January AI as technology pioneers.
Noosheen is also a dedicated alumni of the
GSB ,and member of the Stanford community.
She serves on the advisory board
of the Stanford Institute for
Economic Policy Research, she is
involved with the School of Medicine and
as a member of the GSPs Advisory Council.
Where she is invariably the most involved,
enthusiastic and engaged participant in
discussions about the school and
the future of business and leadership.
Please join me in welcoming
new Noosheen Hashemi.
>> [APPLAUSE] Good afternoon.
Thank you Dean Levin,
faculty, family members and
friends and hello MSX class of 2021.
[APPLAUSE] It is a true
honor to be celebrating this
important milestone with each of you.
Today marks the end of your
time as a GSB student and
the beginning of your
journey as a proud GSB alum.
Not only will you feel deeply
connected to this venerable,
uniquely entrepreneurial and impact
focused institution for decades to come.
But you will also cherish the enduring
friendships that you have nurtured during
your time here.
I know these things to be true
from my personal experience.
While every class is
special in its own way,
this class experienced
something truly extraordinary.
A global pandemic that
upended our world and
shut down even places of worship which
had remained open during two world wars.
Consequently, the fate of this class
convening on this magical campus was up in
the air for a long time.
Eventually four cohorts rather than
the usual three were admitted,
and the year kicked in to gear.
First virtually and then in person and
here's the kicker with no MBAs in sight.
As members of this pre-eminent school
of leadership your class ideated,
advocated and
negotiated the amazing Super Summer.
The most coveted MBA electives
taught just for you,
demonstrating their characteristic
generosity and care.
The administration and faculty obliged and
showed up during summer.
After all, so
much of leadership is about showing up.
You had 11 electives, wow.
When I was a student here,
we only had two.
However, I must say that those two prove
life altering in Jeffrey Pfeffer's
power and politics, among many
cognitions I learned that whistleblowers
who risk everything to do the right thing,
are often feared and not trusted.
Small business with Jim Collins
planted the seeds of entrepreneurship,
warned of people who go back and forth too
many times when accepting a job offer.
And gave us lasting concepts like big,
hairy, audacious goals and
having the right people in
the right seats on the bus.
You seem to have enjoy classes
like new ventures, touchy-feely,
strategic communications,
pass to power and
managing growing organizations
with your beloved Dave Datsun.
Moments of adversity present
our greatest opportunities and
what may have started as a challenging
year for the MSX class of 2021,
ended as one that was truly remarkable.
Now on to the future.
This pandemic won't be the last
world changing event that you will
witness in your lifetime.
In reality, it is only one of the first,
the rate of change is accelerating,
but no longer in a singular direction.
Historically we have experienced
one major revolution at a time.
Our species became anatomically modern
about 300,000 years ago in East Africa.
Around 50,000 years ago we became
behaviorally modern gaining
the ability for symbolic thought.
Around 12,000 years ago,
we have evidence of early agriculture and
the first stationary settlements
around 5,000 years ago, writing.
And mere 250 years ago,
the Industrial Revolution and
the rise of capitalism during
the lifetime of many present here today
in the mid 1990s, the Information Age.
More recently, the lives of almost
everyone here have included the mass
adoption of the internet and
the mobile revolution.
You don't need to be
a statistician to see the trend.
As our collective knowledge and
coordination capabilities
have exponentially increased
the time between each revolution
has exponentially decreased.
Today the speed has become so
rapid that we are in the midst of multiple
revolutions concurrently as they
are not all pointing towards and
they are not all pointing
towards the same future.
Furthermore, not only are these
revolutions happening at the same time,
they're also interacting with and
altering each other,
resulting in highly
unpredictable outcomes.
You're all aware of big technological
phenomenon like the metaverse,
genomics and gene editing, 3D and
4D printing and manufacturing.
5G, autonomous vehicles, natural language
processing, voice interfaces and
chat bots, cloud and edge computing,
blockchains and NF T's, Cobots,
and robotic process automation,
which will affect every single industry.
What about smart devices?
Smart used to just mean connected.
Now it generally means powered
by machine learning algorithms.
Smartphones use AI to improve
the quality of our pictures.
A smart car will use facial recognition to
see if we're paying attention to the road
and alert us if we're getting tired.
Soon smart toilets will use computer
vision to analyze our stool samples and
inform us of gastrointestinal issues.
With IoT, universities,
hospitals and museums,
whole cities in fact, can become
intelligent, proving easy access,
providing easy access,
environmental comfort and security.
Remotely or
autonomously piloted drones and
unmanned aerial vehicles have changed
the face of military operations.
We will see them transform search and
rescue missions, firefighting,
law enforcement and transportation,
drone taxis anyone?
On the life sciences side mRNA
technology of COVID vaccine fame can be
deployed to address a range of
infectious diseases and even cancer.
We've been wearing continuous heartrate
monitors for a couple of decades.
But now more and more these smartwatches
are becoming health devices.
Healthy people are wearing
continuous glucose monitors, and
not too long from now, we'll see
continuous ketone and lactate monitors.
I'm personally counting down
the years to continuous insulin and
the ultimate sensor, cortisol monitors.
Cortisol in forms of chronic stress,
which triggers immune and inflammatory
responses, increasing susceptibility
to diseases like autoimmune,
cardio metabolic and
mental diseases, as well as cancer.
Multiomics integration,
where we combine wearable data,
with data from exposome,
epigenome, microbiome, metabolome,
proteome, transcriptome, genome,
screenome and other omes.
Will deliver whole
person precision health,
where at scale we can predict just
about anything about a person's health.
On the horizon we are seeing nuclear
fusion which if we can bring into
reality will provide an inexpensive
unlimited zero emissions electricity.
Cellular agriculture which produces
animal products from cells rather than
entire animals can change the way we
produce foods like fats and proteins.
Our increasing ability to understand
materials and control matter on a tiny or
nano scale is giving rise to
exciting new materials and
products such as bendable displays.
And inconceivably fast computers capable
of solving seemingly intractable
problems we'll make our current state
of the art technology seem archaic.
These combinations of
permutations are endless, and
their outcomes unprecedented and
mostly unimaginable.
Underlying and overlaying every single
one of these revolutions is AI.
Itself the most
transformative force of all.
Machines will learn and
act intelligently and remodel and
reshape humans and
our planet in unforeseen ways.
But is this all better?
Is it all for the better?
Well, has Facebook connected or
divided us?
Robots handling mundane tasks are good.
How about robot police
officers handling mobs.
Brain computer interfaces can help
disabled people move their prosthetics,
but they can also help militaries take
over minds of their human soldiers.
AI scientists believe that we'll get
to ASI Artificial Super Intelligence,
where machines become self aware, and
surpass the capacity of human
intelligence, and ability by around 2050.
Hopefully as a civilization, we take our
time with AI, and develop it responsibly,
and safely increasing the chances of
ending up with a friendly ASI that
solves every problem on earth
including poverty, climate and aging.
It is not beyond the realm of
possibility though, that governments,
militaries and rogue actors rush towards
AI in a way that leads to a not so
friendly ASI,
hastening the end of our species.
If this sounds over the top,
consider the fact that ASI can come about
in ways that we can't even imagine,
our brains are not even capable of
predicting the things that can happen.
What else is happening around 2050?
Unless water use is drastically reduced,
severe water shortages
will grip the planet.
The World Bank warns we might have more
than 200 million climate refugees.
Just think about it.
1 million refugees destabilize Europe and
split the UK.
The International Union for
Conservation of Nature and
Natural Resources says that if current
trends in overfishing, ocean warming and
pollution continue,
we'll run out of seafood by 2050.
Without a doubt,
these trends and importantly,
the tech accelerated rich poor gap is
likely to lead to massive social unrest.
So what will be the source of calm?
The beacon of stability, the gospel truth,
who will light our path to peace and
happiness?
As the 13th century poem, and
philosopher Rumi said, the universe is not
outside of you look inside yourself
everything that you want you already are.
I believe that you can find your essence
if you look at the data from your
own life objectively.
This requires taking a meta look at
yourself and zooming out of your job,
your family, your network,
your company, even your country.
If you look for
meaning in a specific destination only if
I had this title at that company only if
I started my own business only if I bought
that home or became a member of that club.
You're really setting yourself up for
failure.
In a volatile world those destinations
may change overnight as many of
the many of them did with COVID.
So defining your success,
too narrowly can lead to disillusionment.
Instead of aiming for a destination,
seek out a direction.
Let's call that your NorthStar,
the nexus of what you're good at what
you love and what the world needs.
It will set you up for success and
continuously provide meaning no
matter what turn the world takes.
The first thing to understand
is that what you're good at.
Your innate power derives from your
natural talents, proclivities and
competencies, areas where
you have force multipliers.
If you spend a minute on
something that takes others three,
that's your superpower.
So how do we discover what we're good at?
Do we ask our partner, consult our
performance reviews, survey our friends?
Do we see what we've written on resumes or
backtrack from job
descriptions we want to have?
Those can be valuable but
are often shaped by narratives and
norms rather than the data and insights
from our actual lived experiences.
Rather than trying to catch a reflection
in other's mirrors, we can take
the time to do the work, to reflect and
introspect, find and look at the data.
We inherit powerful methods to get to the
bottom of things from principles of need
finding in design thinking.
To get the right data in front of us,
we need to ask the right questions.
In this case,
the devil is in the semantic details.
You don't want to ask a rephrasing of
the answer you're looking for, like,
what am I good at?
That would query your preconceived
syntheses and notions that are likely
riddled with bias towards your past
decisions or future ambitions.
Instead, we want to query the raw
experiences themselves and
see where those take us.
That way we can cluster
up from the data itself.
In this spirit, a question you could
ask that would help you understand
what you're good at would be when
was a time that I experienced flow?
By using the word when we can recall
specific instances instead of
pre-synthesized notions and flow,
as you may recall, is getting so
immersed and absorbed in doing
something that you lose sense of time.
It is the intersection of a task
that has high difficulty and
one in which you have high competency.
So looking for flow implicitly
queries things that you're good at.
The idea here is to see
ourselves in all our dimensions.
As competencies are not topic specific,
even if they express themselves
in a specific domain the higher
level skill is translatable.
Now that we have our question
we can ideate the answers.
Posted notes on a big blank wall is
a good way to capture your answers.
You want your sponsors to be movable so
you can group them.
Once you have your experiences
laid out say 50 to 100 of them,
cluster them by activity
type to see the patterns.
Once you have your clusters,
you can meta group these to see the
highest level trends or your flow zones.
These are high level competencies
that are domain agnostic,
like analyzing, synthesizing,
presenting, or teaching.
This is the overall method for
each question that creates your NorthStar.
Not only for
finding what you're good at, but
also what you love and
what the world needs.
First you pose a question that queries,
raw experiences related
to that larger question.
Next, you recall as many
experiences as you can,
then you cluster a meta
cluster to find patterns.
After finding what you're good at,
we lay around the topics that you love.
When did it feel like play to do
that thing that you're good at
as opposed to it feeling like work?
When did it feel like play to do that
thing that you're good at as opposed to it
feeling like work?
This clustering reveals the passion zones,
and you will arrive at
what is actually you and
not just the way you've
been presenting yourself.
Often we adopt the passions
of our parents, or
those that our heroes
believe to be worthy.
We should acknowledge and
honor their passions, but
following them is taking
the path of least resistance.
It's easy to do what others want
us to do because it makes money or
is socially celebrated, but these external
sources of passion erode our agency and
make us susceptible to damage
when big changes happen.
We need to hunt down our own assumptions
before a turbulent world does.
Steve Jobs killed the enormously
successful iPod to give life to
the iPhone, management consultants and
investors may have advised them otherwise.
So far our quest for
the north star has been focused on us.
What are we good at and what do we love?
But to try, but to truly find a direction
in life that is nourishing to us,
all the research shows it must
also be nourishing to others.
With that in mind,
what does the world need from you?
You can start to unpack this by asking
when is a time I felt called to serve.
Once again, practice your design
thinking methods, flare out and
focus in generating as many instances as
you can possibly think of going back to
your earliest memories as a child.
Then cluster and
meta cluster to find your purpose zones.
Now, you should have the meta clusters of
what you're good at, what you love and
what the world needs from you.
Your NorthStar lives at the intersection
of these three insights.
Often our job addresses
only one if we're lucky,
leaving us playing catch up on
the other two in our free time.
And for many of us neglecting them
altogether by looking at our data and
following where it points us, we can work
in a way where every minute of work is
nourishing us threefold, intellectually,
emotionally and spiritually.
You may have noticed I didn't
mention material fulfillment.
This is because a,
you know how to make money,
that's how you got to the top
business school in the world.
B, it's overvalued and
ubiquitously covered already.
And C, it does not guarantee peace
of mind, joyful relations or health.
Indeed, it is often our hyper focus
on material accumulation that
deteriorates those sacred and
meaningful things.
Remember this,
every breakthrough in science comes
with a breakthrough in models.
You can't make quantum computers or
nanobots or
nuclear fusion using models from a world
that excludes these possibilities.
To become a radically better leader,
to guide your own life and to positively
influence the lives of others during these
turbulent times, you need a new model.
And we all know what a good model needs,
good data.
The more objectively you collect data
about your life, the better your model and
the great leader you will become.
Our hyperdynamic world needs sober,
stable and energetic leaders.
As MX Sexers, you have already
taken the step to pivot and retool.
Now peel off the accumulated dead weight
of destinations, narratives and norms and
find your North Star.
I leave you with four parting thoughts.
Born of my own lifelong quest for
meaning and impact.
One, learn design thinking,
master it, use it in your work,
home life with friends and
in your end philanthropy.
Two, your biggest
contribution to the world,
maybe taking care of the people
around you, and especially your kids.
Raise your kids yourselves.
Spend time with them.
Get to know them.
Well, in this superficially connected
world, deep connections are priceless.
Have empathy for your kids,
the world we're handing to them is Stormy.
Have high expectations of them, but
do so in the context of the world today,
not the one that your parents lived
in when they were raising you.
And this advice applies
to mentees as well.
Three, health is wealth to
pursue your north star survived
the next pandemic and
to thrive in an explosive world.
Be as healthy and
bio resilient as you can possibly be.
This is a bit hypocritical because
I struggle with this myself.
Yes, I'm a work in progress.
As you know the warranty runs out
around age 40 years around age 40.
So take time to establish a new baselines.
Try a neuro psychology test for cognitive
function and finding your superpowers.
It's not too late to discover how you
learn and lean into those gifts and
insights.
Take a full body MRI,
which can be predictive and
tilt the odds in your favor.
Take your EEG and
EKG early detection blood and stool tests.
And take them again every few
years to see how you're trending.
Explore omics, wear monitors,
and dial your lifestyle.
Adopt healthy habits, food specially
fiber is our biggest lever of health.
Four staying engaged with your class.
Make point of visiting your
classmates when you travel.
Celebrate each others wins and kudos and
shout outs with kudos and shout outs.
Convene on quarterly Zoom calls and
organized reunions.
Take advantage of Stanford's
abundant educational opportunities,
including the D school Institute of
Human Centered Artificial Intelligence and
the New School of Sustainability,
and give to Stanford.
A lot of people gave a lot of themselves
to make this experience possible for
you, be a good ancestor and leave good
things behind for future generations.
Class of 2021 Thank you.
Thank you in advance for the solutions and
thank you in advance for the solutions to
the problems of people and planet that
you will be introducing to our world.
And for the novel blueprints of humble and
human centric leadership,
that we will no doubt
design along the way.
We will all be beneficiaries of
your collective contributions.
And as your fellow Stanford alum,
I will be cheering you on.
You've already given me great hope for
the future .Congratulations.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you very much Nasheen,
that was great advice, especially for
the parents out there.
I thought that was quite helpful.
And a nice perspective on a lot of topics
so thank you so much Nietzschean for
taking the time to be with us and
for those words.
It is my honor to present the MSX Teaching
Award every MSX student takes a core
curriculum covering topics and
accounting Data and decisions ethics,
finance, marketing, micro economics
negotiations, operations and
strategy, organizational behavior and
strategy beyond markets.
Beyond these core courses,
students also take a wide
variety of electives at the GSB.
Each year the MSX class votes
To award a faculty member with
the MSX Teaching Award and
this year the voting process was
coordinated by MSX academic
officers Catherine Garlin House,
Yuki Madota, I'm sorry about that and
Katya Pecha Nee Hina
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thanks to the three of them for
your work on this.
So they they worked very hard because they
had 67 nominations for 22 instructors.
It was obvious that many instructors many
of whom are up on the stage Are beloved
by the students by the MSX class in
disciplines ranging from accounting,
finance and economics to marketing,
management and organizational behavior.
One instructor however, made a
particularly lasting impact on this class.
And it is my great honor to announce
that the winner of this year's
MSX Teaching Award.
This is David Dotson.
>> [APPLAUSE] [APPLAUSE]
>> Described by many
as simply amazing Dave went out of his
way to make class interesting and useful.
It was obvious to the students
that Dave has genuine care for
student well being loves teaching.
And as truly contagious,
I would almost say infectious energy that
was present in every single Interaction.
Multiple students commented on Dave's
efforts to alleviate the experience.
To elevate sorry about that, to elevate
the experience of MSX students and
create a learning environment truly
tailored to this special community.
Practically speaking, Dave, as always,
was incredibly well organized effectively
taught students about useful to toolkits
To align both personal and professional
goals, and change the definitions of
success, happiness and risk taking.
Finally, multiple students commented
that Dave is more than just a teacher.
He's a mentor and a life guide,
whose closing remarks at the end of
the quarter were described as truly
breathtaking and memorable One thing
that makes this award so great is
that Dave was truly as excited and
enthusiastic about his Summer Teaching,
as the students were about having
him teach them long before Dave knew
he was going to win this award.
He was raving to me and
others about his summer MSX mg sections So
congratulations, Dave,
and thank you so much for
all your contributions to this
class's academic experience.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> The late RJ Miller who was the Dean
of the GSB from 1968 to 1978,
Founded the certificate and
public management and
social innovation program here at the GCB.
The certificate program educates
leaders who understand societal issues,
design for and evaluate impact and
understand the specificities of
the management of social organizations in
both the public and the private sectors.
In a world faced with dire global health,
equity and sustainability challenges,
today's certificate programs
take the spirit of our GSB motto
change lives,
change organizations change the world,
to its full potential from
this MSX Cohort we have 11
certificate candidates their names
are listed in the program and
I offer you all congratulations
on completing that,
>> [APPLAUSE] [APPLAUSE]
We will be announcing graduation awards at
a later time as final calculations
are going on as we speak.
Those awards include
recognizing the top 10 attended
the class as Robert L Josh scholars.
Bob Josh who this is named
after has joined us today, so
thank you for being here Bob.
[APPLAUSE]
And about six or
seven of you will have be attached
to Bob for the rest of your lives.
The top student in the class
the person with the highest GPA
in GSB classes will be awarded
the George GC Parker Award.
George had full intentions
of being here today,
I think he got his regalia was all set and
at the last minute was called
away to a another meeting that
he couldn't possibly miss.
He sends his regrets and
he asked me for an excused absence,
which I'm going to go ahead and
grant him, but
we'll be happy to announce the winner
of that award very, very soon.
Before I hand over the podium,
I wanted to just say a few things
about the MSX class of 2021.
Since March of 2020, I'm so
sick of saying unprecedented,
I cannot tell you.
We throw that word around too much and
there's a lot of stuff that's been
unprecedented, but it is an understatement
to say the challenges faced by
this class were unprecedented.
They were truly exceptional..
As a group,
you showed amazing resilience in waiting
six extra months to start the program.
You arrived in the Bay Area at basically
the high point of the epidemic.
And you did the first half
of the program with hardly
an opportunity to leave your
apartments and meet your classmates.
Those were amazing challenges and
you all face those and
made the best of it and
we really appreciate that.
Despite that, this class was an extremely
academically engaged group and
you found a group of leaders and I want to
give a special shout out to Felipe,
JY, Catherine, Nicole, Katya, Hannah,
I've probably forgotten a few others and
I apologize for that.
I want to give a special shout out to
all of them for their dedicated work.
[APPLAUSE].
That group I mentioned and
some others were dedicated advocates for
all of you as their classmates,
they truly were.
And they were wonderful partners
to the GSB administration for
which we're very grateful.
So I want to thank them and all the rest
of you for your flexibility and teamwork,
to make the most of this very challenging
time and of your overall GSB experience.
This is the end of the journey,
I know it was very different from what you
anticipated when you
applied to the MSX program.
I know that like any MSX class,
it's a transformative experience and
your lives have been forever changed.
And while all the experiences you
envisioned had to be altered and
were constrained, I hope you will look
back fondly on your time here at the GSB.
And I also hope you're going to
stay involved with the GSB.
You're moving from the student
community into our alumni community and
as I hope you've already seen,
our alumni play an important part
in the academic experience here.
And it's my wish that you too will engage
with GSB academic mission as alumni,
give your time and
experience generously to future classes.
I can say a lot more about what
the MSX program can mean for
students, but
who better than our graduates to
talk about their
experiences this past year?
If I had to choose one word to describe my
experience, it would be Transformative.
My one word to describe
this year is eye opening.
A word to describe my MSX experience
this year would be great.
Exceptional Unforgettable.
My experience in MSX is filled with love.
Family Growth Transformation.
If there's one word that I can
use to describe my experience at
the GSB is belief.
Amazing.
Deciding.
Inspiration.
Transformational.
The word that I'd use to
describe my MSX experience is on.
World opener.
Life changing.
Mind blowing.
Exhilarating.
Incredible.
I came in with an idea of
what it might be like, but
I've been constantly surprised at every
turn by the people that I've met,
the experiences that I've had, and
just the overall energy of this place.
Before I came, I was doubtful, but
I am sure this was the best
decisions I ever made.
This year at the GSB,
I've changed my definition of success,
happiness and taking risks.
The relationships both with my class and
across the GSB are what has made
this experience truly spectacular.
For some of us confidence can
be a revolutionary thought and
the GSB community, students, alumni and
professors have been given me
all the reasons to believe in myself
as they are my role models in their
beliefs of making a change for
this world, It is the people,
the students, the teachers, alumni,
that make this place so special.
The thing that surprised me the most about
my time at Stanford was how humbling
it can be.
Now, there were certainly a lot of
areas where I felt that my talents and
strengths were reinforced but
this place challenged me Unequivocally,
most grateful for
the people that I've met here.
I love GSB, I love Stanford and
I love my family who strongly
supported me throughout the year,
Stanford made my world bigger,
I enjoyed every single day of the program.
Stanford has opened my mind to new ideas,
expanded my view of
what I'm capable of and
connected me with lifelong relationships.
But the MSX has meant to me, understanding
that there are no crazy ideas.
The thing that I'm going to take away from
this experience is the Stanford mantra.
It's to change lives,
change organizations, and
change the world and I'm going to
do that in the health care space.
I love you all.
Thank you so much, it was an amazing year.
[APPLAUSE]
Is that a great video,
thank you everybody who contributed
even those who couldn't stick to the one
word limit.
Finally I'd like to now introduce
Associate Dean Garth Saloner,
who will read the names of MSX degree
candidates as they walk across the stage
Hareesh Pattu.
[APPLAUSE]
Tiffany Ashley Bell.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Bill Alexander Vanessi.
>> Daniel Bernstein.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Tripp Bhatia.
>> Zachary Blaisdell.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Katrina Carey.
>> Pradeep Singh Chawla.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Marty Tommy Lin Chen.
>> Hana J Cho.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Becas Chaudhry.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Theo Tu.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Mali Quenbator.
>> Luis Carlos Cruz.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Shota Dido.
>> Isabela Vie Andrade Adohu.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Alexey Dynaway.
>> Catherine Lilly French.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Jose Martinez Fuentes Mattioli.
>> Catherine Elizabeth Garlin House.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Kunal Ghosh.
>> Honey Rude Goldacor.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Phillippi Freitas.
>> Mimi Kuptat.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Jun Haneda.
>> Sarah Jane.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Sin Laxiwy.
>> Leon Lack.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Wenny Le.
>> Ryan Leonard Paid.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Jay Ywan.
>> Nabeel Missouri.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Michael John Maximo Jr.
>> Yuki Misota.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> IKadeem Norcan Nova.
>> Morgan Joseph O'Brien III.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Jason Ouma Honey.
>> Kathia Patches Nina.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Giacomo Pellegrini.
>> Pablo Rivera de Nera Otador.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Kate Manning Rogers.
>> Michael Fedin.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Eduardo Liao.
>> James Patrick Treffer.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Tony Lean Fung Shun.
>> Dr. Madu Sheti.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Maria Fernanda Sierra Perreah.
>> Kathy Katia Soul.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Nicole Christina Renee Swanson.
>> Michael Titus.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Josh Vanderlip.
>> Tomas Vargas.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Andre Ventura Fernandez.
>> Lindo Wilson.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Prashant Yata.
>> Cada Yamaguchi.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Lie Yee.
>> Alexandria Lauren Yet.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Lulu You.
>> Xian You.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Ryan G N Joe.
>> Edmond Joey Zhao.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Nicolas Siporovic.
>> Graduates, guests, faculty and staff,
this concludes the 2021
MSX graduation ceremony at
the Stanford Graduate School of Business.
I have to say that seeing all of you up on
that screen, talking about the program and
walking across the stage leaves me with
a great feeling of optimism and hope for
the future.
And before we leave the auditorium for
the reception in the Lacus Courtyard
which I hope everyone will attend,
let's have one final round of applause for
the graduating class.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Congratulations MSX class of 2021.
And now, let me ask the guests
to please remain in your seats.
We will recess out from CMX auditorium,
the faculty, then the graduating class and
then please all join us across
the street at Biddle Lacus Courtyard for
the reception.
So congratulations class of 2021.
[MUSIC]